thank you so much for having me uh it's
a real pleasure to
be in this conference and today what i
want to talk about
is how i hear a lot of people and a lot
of stories of how
react is easy and how getting
started with react takes like i don't
know in five minutes you're going to get
everything done first i want to point
out that nothing in programming is easy
programming is hard don't let anyone
tell you that something is easy
but i don't think react is
that hard but what's hard about react
is navigating the entire world of react
there's so many things
in react that can kind of get lost
even if react itself is not hard and you
know how to use all the states and all
the
all the effects and everything it's
still hard
because you have to make all these
libraries that hate each other talk to
each other
and somehow like each other and that's
hard
when to know when to use something and
when not to use something and blah blah
blah
and as an example to that i want to
explain to you how i learned react
so uh back in my early days when i was a
sweet summer child
i think i was like 2 23 or something i
don't know i would have to go on
linkedin to check but i don't know my
password so
i'm going to go with 23. i was like 23
and i worked for this company
i worked in like the uh payment
management system of it
and we had to build a new payment system
which was paypal everyone knows paypal
so that makes it so much easier to tell
this talk
uh and we had to go paypal and there was
me another guy
and there was me a guy and another girl
on my team as front ends
this was the also the only time i've had
ever had more than men
male women than men in my team it never
happened again don't get your hopes up
it's not a portuguese thing it happened
once
and this this guy was super nice uh and
he had this idea that like okay so we
should use react for this react is this
new thing
and it looks really good and we should
use it
and it was always like ahead of the
curve and stuff like you made the first
babel jsx plug-in and all that stuff
like really smart guy 10 out of 10.
um problem was no one else knew how to
use react like i didn't know how to use
react and my friend also didn't know how
to use react
but we were like okay that's fine like
we'll learn whether or not to use react
let's use react so what happened was he
like this was before create three after
app so he made like the entire webpack
thing and danny went on vacation for
three weeks
so he left for three weeks and my friend
also left for three weeks so it was me
the sweet summer child that was left
there alone
wondering what the is happening
here
that was not good times so uh the point
of this is
that i kind of had to figure it out so i
had to build this thing i had to build
this paypal integration i didn't have to
do the back end obviously like someone
already did the back end
i had to do this paypal integration and
i had no idea what the i was
supposed to do
i came from angular 1 respect
i came from angular 1 and like in
angular 1 like
people just gave you things like you
know you want to route here
like you just put a rod in there it's
easy there you go
uh then it scaled and you cried but in
the beginning it was like oh wow this is
easy like i didn't even know that much
javascript like i joined that company
because they were impressed by my
flexbox knowledge
um so i tried to figure it out and what
happened by the end was that i
didn't quite understand the idea of like
front-end
npm packages at the time like i knew
they were real
but i didn't know you had to use them
this much
so i tried to do everything with just
react and the way that i did for example
routes was that
so i had this like app.js right and then
you had all the buttons like the nap
buttons and when you click the nav
button it just toggled the state to like
about equals true and if about was true
it showed another component
which in like in retrospect may not be
the best way to create things and react
and then
like so like the in the final of these
three weeks like this app
worked kinda but it was the worst code
that you would ever see and react
because i tried to do every single thing
with react because i didn't know
any better literally i didn't know any
better
like no one told me that i could go on
the internet and look for packages that
did the thing that i wanted them to do
so then my friend came back and he was
like why didn't you use a routing
library and i was like what's a routing
library
it was like you put it into react and it
does routing for you
and i was like oh you mean like with the
things and everything and he was like
yeah i was like oh oh that that sounds
better so after that
it was all the way up because i feel
like i started right at the bottom
we finished that but then you forget
that we had to integrate it in an
angular 1 app
because the rest of the app was angular
1. so i feel like i need to tell you
that
if there was this like react app that
was the paypal app
and then we had the angular 1 app and
like the thing that was connecting them
was polymer
i don't know i know that i left and when
i came back and like it was like hey
guys what's up
oh look we made polymer and i was like
why
okay so after that i eventually
went on the npms and create packages and
stuff and like
realize how the world works but i
shouldn't know that like this is not
that weird like i feel like it happened
to a lot of us mostly the ones that came
from angular 1.
um respect and like
there were no snake managements in
angular 1 like the same management was
the window
so good uh yeah so my name is sarah
sarah vieta i'm a developer i got
sandbox i
am nikithaftw intruder i am originally
from portugal so
if you want to ask questions in spanish
i will understand them
i may try to speak but i'll probably say
portuguese words in the middle of it
then you'll be like
what that sounds spanish but it's not
spanish
that's probably because i'm speaking
portuguese with a spanish accent because
that's how all of us do it i apologize
in advance
so yeah that's kind of what i want to
say is react is not hard but the
ecosystem itself is very confusing
and very big and daunting and yeah
yeah so okay so what we're gonna do
today we're gonna have some fun
at 10 am well the world may be dying
somewhere else but we'll not think about
that
and we're gonna build an app all right
so this app is going to be incredibly
over engineered
but like amazingly of an engineer so
we're going to use routing we're going
to use animations all of these will be
external libraries state management and
css and js
so we're going to use all of these
things and i want to say that you don't
quite need a state management in this
situation i think
you could probably get away with just
using context but i wanted to show you a
state management
because like there will be a point where
you're using context that if your app
gets too
big you will lose contact
and i don't know i thought that was
funny i don't write my jokes they just
come out because i'm so nervous
okay so let's do it okay so
what we're gonna build is this beautiful
and who would have known i'm using code
sandbox
um yeah so i have an endpoint that has
the worst
30 movies it has i think 100. the worst
30 movies
according to mdb these are the ones that
have the least rating according to amdb
why is this important now you know
the worst technically the worst movie
ever made was disaster movie
that makes sense so what is this so
this is going to get from a graphql api
and it's going to show me a list of
movies
and it's going to append some likes to
it so then you can like a movie it's
going to give you this little cute
animation
and it's going to order them by likes um
yeah so then you can also click one of
these and then you'll see this
the very back quality of this image and
the actual rating
which is honestly 2.0 out of 10 which is
really bad i don't think i've ever seen
this movie
okay yeah so one thing is that it's not
saved in any local storage or anything
so i don't know but i really like this
animation i think it took me longer than
literally building anything else in this
app
this little thing look at this little
thing okay
so this is what i have right and i won't
be live coding a lot because
mostly because i don't have time
i guess uh but i'll be like i have the
app on my side and i'll be copying and
pasting whatever makes sense
first so what i have right now is that i
have all the pages
empty and i already have all the things
installed so let's go over what i have
installed
so these three things these which what
is that react scripts react and react
dom come with cra
creates react app so then i also have
framer motion installed
history react dom and react router dom
for
react dom uh what you need three because
you need three
um uh framer motion animations we have
over my den over my react so this is
what i'm going to use for state
management so i already have a folder
here called overmind
and style components which is going to
use for css and i also have
normalized.css
which what it does is basically make
everything look the same
[Music]
so if i do this could not find module
and
that's a good start it just basically
removes like a bunch of margins and
stuff i don't think it's doing anything
though no it is it is you see that
you see that there we go we remove the
margin there
yeah so this is the only thing so yeah
we're done normalized
um yeah so let's get started so
the first thing that we need if you look
at the app is that we need to fetch
these right
and i want to fetch them using the um
state management system so i have some
things here and the two things that i
have are the queries so i have a query
to get
all the movies and i have a query to get
one movie and
i have this because i didn't really want
to use apollo
because even though this app is very
overkill i didn't want to overkill it
even more
so i want to just like shed some light
on graphql in this case
which is like it's just a fetch like
technically graphql is just a fetch but
sent as a post
that's it like there's no weird magic
because
uh what's gonna keep track of my cash is
gonna be over mine which is the state
management so i don't need apollo
i just need a fetch so we're waiting
fetch of the endpoint that i
that i have here which is the end point
of the movies
and then i'm passing a headers telling
you that it's json and stringifying
whatever i pass in here
that's it and it returns the data so
then i can do whatever you want whatever
i want i mean you can also do whatever
you want it's up to you
okay so let's get started right
let's do this okay so let's get started
with the index and this is the index of
overmind
so the first thing that we want to do is
get all the movies
so let me uh import
the queries
okay so if i do things like i click
things and nothing happens
i can explain so i have a windows and a
mac
and it's very confusing because i
couldn't make the keyboards work the
same way
and it's just very confusing so let me
import queries
oh if i mis-type things that has nothing
to do with it that's just
how i do things fetch data from
and let me get kick you well okay so the
first thing that i want to do is that i
need to create a config for it
so i'm going to export cons config
and this needs a state and sorry we use
typescript sandbox and it always has
like the two dots thing
so this config is gonna have state and
actions
so state is the state and actions is
anything that can change the state
i don't know the name of it in redux but
it's like that thing in redux
that's not even the thing in reader it's
like the set state it's like a set stick
i don't know redux i'm sorry i did back
in my day
there we go beautiful okay so we need
movies right
so and it's going to start as an empty
array cool so now we need an action
and this is the action that will create
the movies
that will get the movie sorry and so i'm
going to create an action and these are
all functions and i'm going to create
one called get movies
and this is going to be async right good
and then in here we're going to get the
states so
when you create any action it gets the
sp there we go
i read someone was in the audience being
like you missed a comma
i'll get there i'll get there eventually
um i know because i'm that person uh
yeah so you get the states
uh and you also get the all the actions
whatever you want to do
so let's get to movies and let's say
const beta
equals a weight because this is an async
i can do weight
fetch data so i call the fetch beta and
then i
passed the query no wait
i pressed that the body sorry the body
is query
equals where is that
movies okay cool and then this is
let's just return um
yeah let's not return anything sorry
let's say speaker movies
equals data.movies and that's it we can
also destructure this
and say yes and now we don't need data
it's kind of mutable kind of does
everything behind the scenes so you
don't have to
let's create a homepage since we're at
it and let's actually add
um react router i think that makes sense
so this part i'm going to copy so here
you go react router dom
loaded like a good first thing and there
we go and let me
import home which doesn't exist yet
we'll create it
and there we go and i'm gonna create
these two routes
wait i got this i promise i got this
this is more like this will be needed in
the future and now
add a line comment
okay expected string got absolutely
nothing because this page doesn't exist
okay so cons home equals a function that
gets nothing
and then let me export default home
there we go and then we import all the
things that i need to import
so i need to import react and use effect
and i need to use actually over mind
but i'm not it's not set up yet so let's
do that first now
so it's a lot of back and forth in the
beginning until we get all this stuff
set up
but we need a provider so we need to
import the provider like
like literally every single like library
in the world
we need to import a provider and we also
need to import the config
that comes from overmind that we created
over minds and there we go so now we
need the provider
and close this provider that is the
provider from overmind
and we also need to create overmind
which basically you pass at the config
and that's it
so you can say const state or whatever
uh equals create overmind
and you pass the conflict and now the
value of this
provider the value equals state
and that's it maybe uh
home returning okay nothing was returned
from render
[Music]
we can sub there we go
so now the way you use a verb a lot of
times is that you say const
state equals use over mind
but as you can see this doesn't really
exist right now so
let's create this real fast and this is
just one
single thing which you can say from here
so like in your index or whatever you
want
use over mind equals create hook
and that's it so when you create a hook
in over an overmind it gives you
the use over mind
and this will allow you to say so if i
say state equals
is over mine so imports
uh i was doing the windows one again uh
use
overmind from
back back no overnight
there we go and now if i console
download the state
we have a movie's an array of zero
that's something right
that is something we're getting
somewhere here uh
and now we need to go get movies okay so
i also need the actions
so actions and unload so use effect
i know i said i wasn't going to light
code
but i'm failing at that actions that get
moving
also i want to say that if you use
typescript
the above error actions that i get movie
is not a function
because it's getting movies
and there we go okay so
now if i reload this page i should be
able to get to movies
i should be able to say state
at movies the map
that was pretty not smart
and now let me json.stringify
there we go now we get all the movies
jesus christ i got really excited there
um and now we got all the movies it's
not
hard i mean it's it's hard but as look
when you get the hang of it it gets
easier
we also want to add likes to it and
start it all at zero so i'm just going
to map
get a movie and then in each of the
movie
i want to say that whatever is returned
from it
is equal to movie and then god
comma there we go and likes equals zero
that did not work because i'm missing
one there we go
so now when i reload this page we should
get like likes
which again likes equals zero oh good so
now i'll show you something really cool
about overmind and this one i'm just
going to copy and paste because
otherwise
i am going to forget one of these
comments
so let me import derived as well
i'm gonna go over what this magic is
so let me come here and actually map
over order movies which gonna give you
the same thing
but the magic of this is that when you
create something like this
a derived function derives
i know english right the right function
what it does is that it gets the state
you currently have and creates something
else
so if you want to sort something if you
want to say that does this have likes i
want to get all the movies ordered all
the time
you don't have to do it in your view you
can save it in your state and when this
movie's updates
this will update automatically it's
really nice like you'll get access to
this
um sandbox uh okay so let's actually
create a
home page and this is gonna
yeah let's create the homepage and this
is gonna make us create some components
so the first component i need is this
main component so this is where we're
gonna start using
style components so all that i'm saying
is like display this says flex
that's it and have a max width of 600
for some reason i want 800
and we're going to have on the side and
that's about it so in here what i want
to do is i want to enter
main this is going to do it yes it did
it
did it it imported it
it imported it that's beautiful and i
still screwed up wait there we go
oh yes okay let me check something yes
see
oh that's why i wanted 600 so that i
could it could be like visible
okay so yeah that's done we need some
global state though so let's add that
so that it looks prettier when you load
it so
you can have global states with um
stock components by creating create
global state which this comes from
so i'm gonna it's a lot of talking
imports
and this is going to be normalized
uh so i don't really need normalize here
anymore oh yeah that's already there and
now this is a component so we can just
mount this component
that's that's why i added that it's like
i prepared
okay so that looks better i mean it
doesn't look good
but it looks better so we can keep going
uh i would say the next step
is to when you load the page
like there is no loading or anything so
let's create a fancy loading i think
that's important
or that's my definition of important uh
so we have a loading here which just has
two divs and then there's a fancy
animation don't think i did this because
i copied this out of the internet
if you type css loading you get that
um and in here i can say if not
state that ordered movies that link
yes i think that's it return
domain and then be loading
and believe this is actually important
things that's so beautiful see who needs
typescript
there we go now we have a loading okay
we're getting places
let's add some more stuff so in the
homepage
i'm gonna add a movies component
which is not going to make sense right
now but i promise you
it will make sense in the future so this
is just going to be a ul
and we're also going to import styled
so i don't know how to like go up on
your keyboard thing so i just select
everything and go up or down
like a lazy person import style
from components and now we have this
movies thing
and so maine is gonna get movies
and i'm gonna close this movies i hope
you're wearing something
and what i want to do now is
show this there we go
okay cool so this just shows if not or
not
please show me the voting if not give me
the movies
so let's create this movie component
this is just a general uh component
that uh we'll just show the movie itself
so i'm gonna come here and i'm literally
gonna copy and paste this one because
there we go so now now
i did not import it did i no i did
i did oh no oh no we have issue
exporting fault movies you may have
clicked the render method of movie
i don't like i don't like having these
issues live
this does not make me happy because you
need to understand
that like as soon as someone who's doing
a conference talk
has any problems they immediately have
never seen react in their life
i'm like what is this what is this i
don't know what this is this doesn't
make any sense
uh okay oh i think the problem is this
we don't have this like button yet
that that'd be the problem yeah and
there we go that was the problem
okay but we do have a problem here i
mean we do have the like button problem
we need to create the like movie action
okay so let's go to overmind
which is all the way over here and
create a
like movie let me go to my trusted
sidekick um at least i'm not lying to
you
it should be like magical if code just
showed up like that's how i code you
know it just shows up
it's like magic um yeah so what the hell
am i doing here
so we have an action that also gets the
state and then as a second parameter it
gets anything that i pass it to so in
this case i passed the id
uh that we get as a prop so if i come
here to the home you can see that i
spread all the props
and i give it a key and that's it and
then
let me close this loading and dismay and
we get the silver mind
and so we say state that movies data
movies okay there we go equals
on map and if the movie id that we're
mapping over
has the same idea as the one i sent
please add one to the likes
so now we just need to add the like
button
uh this one is mostly css
there we go see all css and now we need
the star which is that 3d animation that
took me
forever because i couldn't get framer
motion to work with style components
i even broke with sandbox in the process
and i was like why is my sandbox broken
turns out you can't use the css thing of
style components
with uh frame remote
but i mean the error was that motion
wasn't defined so it's like
right okay so there's also another thing
here is that
in the like button if i come here we
check if it has likes
so let me remove this for now so i'm
just gonna do this
and this and i'm gonna add one comment
i reload this page we should see the
movies
and i should and i repeat should be able
to like a movie there we go
did you see that there's an animation
it's so pretty
uh i forgot one thing i mean it's not
important at all
but it's a h1 here
worst movies ever made
[Applause]
and i'm gonna close the second one oh
wow that is not a closed h1
oh yeah so that cannot be in the main
because the main is black
okay there we go do you know how many
times that happens to me
i'm just gonna plug this in here oh no
that's a flex component i can't do that
it's going to break my entire app uh so
i'm going to add an h1 here that's
basically just a lenses to the center
um and so this is h1
really do it that's the real question it
did
okay right movie like movie wait what
yes that was a good 10 box plug i mean i
will have to fix it either way
but that's a problem for future
okay so we need to check if it has likes
right so that's the
basically the only thing we need here
right now so i'm going to leave this
disabled
state that has likes is not a function
so what what is my idea here
so my idea is to disable it if it has
any likes so what i want to do is create
another derived state
that will check if there are likes there
and if there are return me true or false
uh so let me just find the page and so
i'm here right
okay cool and this is the right state
and this is where
it gets confusing and i'll give you that
one
very easily so like i don't know but
when you pass a value to any um
it's not this one is it not this one
yeah
when you pass a value to any derived
property it actually gets passed as a
second
function so like the function returns a
function just go to the docs and copy
the example and change it that's what i
did
um and then i say like movies that finds
movie if movie that id
when the find the movie where the movie
that id is equal to the id that i just
passed
and return if the likes are different
than zero so if the likes are different
than zero returns meanwhile and disables
the button
uh one thing is that i use this because
sort by default is mutable
and you can mute this you can't mute the
state here like you have to use an
action so it
gives you an error saying that you can't
mute the state so this will create a
copy
of that array and then you can sort it
there is no like non-destructive way of
doing sorts in javascript
javascripts javascripts that's all i got
to say
okay so we done it we got 30 movies
that's it so now
we just need to make the new page we're
almost there we're almost there
we're going to do this we're going to do
this and no one's going to have a panic
attack what are panic attacks
okay so we need to create this new page
so the first thing i'm going to do is
remove this beautiful
and import a movie from oh no i click my
my mouse that can like go fast or slow
i don't know why anyone would want their
mouse to go like incredibly almost
unbelievably slow uh moving
i'm gonna give you an error because
movie is basically nothing
and now uh we can see from here that
this path will be movie slash id and
this is the name of the param so if i
name this law
i can then get it as param equals lol
i'll show you what i mean okay i'll show
you what i mean so i'm gonna import
react
let me just copy the import react and
use overmind and all of that
because there's no point in watching me
type imports
i think i mean i don't think that's the
fun part of live coding watching someone
be like import free act from react
const movie is this
but backwards and let me return
i just so it stops complaining and then
export
defaults there we go
if i can type there we go is it gonna
work yeah
yes great all good right okay so now
there is this thing called use params so
i can say const
wall equals use for rams
like this and if i do a console log of
lull
you get one because that's the id but
we're going to call it id i mean we can
keep it as low honestly let's keep it as
low unless that makes it entertaining
right right just looking
watching people code is not the funniest
thing okay so uh let me copy over the
css the css that i have here
garcia and then what i want to do
is that uh i think this is
fine yeah let's go to overmind
and let's get the new one so i wanna
create something here
which is uh like a single page a single
movie
so i'm gonna create single movie
okay cool this is gonna be an empty
object by default so i guess i can just
copy and paste the things that i have
here
because that's fine uh so in here i can
just
come here and say prompt uh
sorry i think i just had a plain part
equals use overmind
and do not return this but return
there we go oh my god i am so sorry
it's not good it's here and what i'm
gonna do how i'm gonna create this is
that i'm gonna say
cons current movie i think i'm running
out of time
i have five minutes
i thought the stock was gonna be like 20
minutes glad it wasn't um
i guess that would have been a failure
equals state that single movie
[Applause]
and this is not id anymore this is law
because that's what we decided as a
family
remember um
and what does this even mean this means
that i'm going to create an object that
is going to have the id of the movie
so like one and then the
object what what is the great thing of
this in like if i just paste the movie
in here
because then if i go to the homepage and
go back to one that's already gonna be
in state
so it's just a really nice way of doing
these things and i also want to say that
if there are no current movies
just show me the loading so like if this
is empty
which is always empty now
uh and on use effect i want to call
actions that get movie
actions and pass the law not the id jd
is nothing now
we don't like the idea anymore okay
let's get this movie
uh and get movie it's gonna be pretty
similar to this one
so get movie this is gonna get the state
and this is also gonna get an id
and so i want the query is queries that
movie
and then the variables that i pass
are id i think
maybe no
no actually that's it that's that's uh
actually kind of
yeah no that's pretty much it so this
doesn't get things
this gets something called movies by pk
which is the name that the back end has
for this and so what we do
is that we say state that singular movie
single movie and then the id equals
movie not movies this is
a singular one now
we have this it works
i honestly did not expect this to work
i'll be honest with you right now
i was gonna be honest as a family here i
did not expect that to work
i think we're done oh my god and with
three minutes
i think we're done so what i want to
show you here is that
creating an app with react is not just
about react
also ignore this it just asks me like
please include action i mean
you should include lol bro that's
important wrong is our id
um include actions which doesn't make a
lot of sense in this case because it's
like
it's a function and if it gets rebuilt
every time you're just gonna keep doing
this and i don't want that
so yeah we did this i am very proud of
us
okay okay so i'm gonna share this
sandbox but what i wanted to show you
about this is that
most of what we did actually wasn't
react
most of what we did was try to make
libraries work with each other
and uh try to find our own paths to make
things work
so that's what i want to show is that
react
maybe not the hardest thing but
navigating react is
hard so this is the code 10 box link
don't worry i i sent this to the
organizers
they'll put it on slack or something
because i mean you can try to memorize
this
uh you only need to memorize this
because the rest you can type whatever
you want
don't tell us don't tell this don't
don't tell them that i said this
um it's a bug um yeah so the tools that
i used were over my j i also shared the
slides
over my js which is a really nice
server-side tool of
what client state tool it also actually
has
graphql support but i thought that was
more confusing so i
ended up removing it and just using
fetch i was like i'll use apollo
then i was like no that's too much i'll
just over mine graphql that's too much
i'll just use fetch
people need to go back to our roots uh
stock opponents
framework motion which is what creates
this anime i forgot to show you about
the animation sorry
uh so you just pass an animate so you
have a motion and then you have the name
of whatever
um thing you're creating it's kind of
like style that's something so in this
case it's an svg
this is basically my initial things and
then you pass animate
and what this does is that i say when
it's liked that i pass to it it goes to
minus a hundred
and the y and it goes that comes back
uh it automatically does the going back
things look
really nice so i used here
and as you can see i just passed likes
to it
and that's it i passed liked and light
is set over here in the movie
and what i do is that i set liked and
then i set a timeout
that sets it back to false in 500
milliseconds
and i also use react router the version
i used is six
uh because six allows you to do this
that i really like that you just by you
pass the component and then in the
component you give it a path like i
prefer this
so you gotta use six in five you have
the route component
it's basically the same thing this is
just synthetic sugar that i like
yeah uh i wrote a book about all this
stuff
if you'd be interested in if you like my
sense of as you can see this was
screenshot
on the windows i'm not lying um
yeah i'm terrible at marketing but if
you
liked my talk and you would like to get
my book there is a
discount if you're from mexico not only
if you're from mexico that would have
been weird and i'll be like
my wife is from there so everyone get a
discount thank you
for giving me a wife uh there's purchase
parody
so if you're from basically not germany
or the u.s you will probably get a
discount
thank you so much